Problem solving is extremely important to us, because not a day goes by that we
don't have to implement some type of problem solving strategy. Every test we do
that we don't necessarily know how to do forces us to solve a problem. There
are many strategies to solve different kinds of problems. For example, basic
mathematical problems use algorithms. And algorithms are step by step formulas
or procedures used to solve a problem. For example, you use an algorithm when
you're trying to do long division. These step by step procedures work really
well when there's a clear, yet unknown solution to a problem, these kinds of
problems are called, convergent problems. They have a known solution and your
thinking has to converge or narrow down on the correct solution. Other problems
have no known solution, or many different solutions. These are called Divergent
problems. This requires thinking that broadens and diverges to come up with a
possible solution. Now for these kinds of problems, A good strategy to use is
insight or the Eureka strategy. This involves lots of thinking, you might be
stumped for a little while, put the problem aside for a little while. Then all
of a sudden the solution will just hit you. The problem to this, is it can't be
taught, like algorythms can.